- Well, you did a
freestyle for us last time
you were here.
- Yeah.
- So would you be willing
to build on that this time?
I don't know, maybe with my band.
(audience cheers and applauds)
- [Kelly] Would you be...
- Yeah, absolutely.
- Just sayin', like we need a topic.
So how about parenthood in
honor of your new little one?
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] How about parenthood?
- I need you to help me
vent though, because-
- Okay, I can do this.
- So, okay, so I know
you're, you have two kids.
- We have two, yeah.
- River Rose.
- And Remy B.
- And Remy B,
and I just want you to tell
me a couple things, please,
about both of them, if you don't mind,
that drive you crazy about them.
- Oh, things I can say on air.
Oh (laughs).
- [Utkarsh Ambudkar] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Oh, okay I'm gonna start with the son,
'cause I need a minute
on my daughter (laughs).
My son, he never picks anything up.
- Yeah.
- And my daughter is always surprised,
she's about to be nine, y'all.
Always surprised about having to go to bed
in her own bed, for some reason,
like and can't get in mine.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Love it.
- [Kelly] Get out!
Yeah.
- Do they fight with each other?
- Yes, but they're also,
they're equally buddies
but they're equally...
Yeah, they're frenemies.
- Frenemies.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
- Okay.
- [Kelly] But he, I don't understand.
It's like he isn't capable.
It's like the plague,
he won't touch it again.
Like, it's on the floor,
he already touched it,
he's not gonna touch it and pick it up.
I don't know what that is.
- All right, I think that might be enough.
- It's a lot, I can tell you (laughs).
- Well, I mean I could get more,
but I know this segment has
to be 90 seconds or less.
- Okay, let's walk over
to the band, let's do it.
(audience cheers and applauds)
(Kelly laughs)
- Okay, hand me my mic, hand me my mic.
What am I doing?
'Cause I can't rap.
- Okay, let's do it.
You guys ready?
(boppy hiphop music)
- Okay, I'm nervous.
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah. ♪
♪ These are the things I do, uh ♪
♪ The things I do, uh ♪
♪ These are the things I do
that make my mama go crazy ♪
♪ These are the things I do ♪
♪ Yeah, the things I do, uh ♪
♪ These are the things I do
that make my mama go crazy ♪
♪ Hey Mama, it's Remy ♪
♪ Yo, look around, uh ♪
♪ All of my (beep) is
all over the ground, uh ♪
♪ That's right ♪
♪ You need a little more
wine up in your cup ♪
♪ 'Cause you better guarantee ♪
♪ That I'm never gonna pick 'em up ♪
♪ Hey Mama, it's River Rose ♪
♪ Question in my head ♪
♪ Yo, why the hell can't
I sleep in your bed? ♪
- I dunno, but you're there.
♪ Come on, let get up in them sheets ♪
♪ No, no ♪
♪ Please Mama, please Mama,
I want to go to sleep, yeah ♪
♪ Hell, no ♪
♪ These are the things I do, yeah ♪
♪ The things I do, yeah ♪
♪ These are the things I do
that make my mama go crazy ♪
♪ These are the things I do, yeah ♪
♪ The things I do ♪
♪ The things I do, yeah ♪
♪ These are the things I do
that make my mama go crazy ♪
♪ It's Remy B, hey ♪
♪ And River Rose, yeah ♪
♪ Remy is dropping and River's
picking her nose, yeah ♪
♪ Kelly knows, yeah ♪
♪ Sipping on the vino ♪
♪ Aw here we go with the
Kelly Clarkson show ♪
♪ So, so, so these are the things I do ♪
♪ The things I do ♪
♪ These are the things I do
that make my mama go crazy ♪
♪ These are the things I do, I do ♪
♪ I do, I do ♪
♪ These are the things I do
that make my mama go crazy ♪
(audience cheers and applauds)
- You are so good!
- You are too.
That was great!
I'm shaking.
- I just love when I sang, "No, no."
- Yeah (laughs).